PASSED A BILL THAT INCLUDERECORE
HUNDREDS O GRE
ENERGY AND HEALTH CARE
THE BILLS
CHOR
TO BE FOR DEMOCRATS.
MR.  PRESIDENTPRECIATEININ
INFON
ACT WAY THE HOUSTHIS
AFTERNOON, PELI CALLED HISTORICV
SENATOR RNHAEN
BILL DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGHEE
SMALL STEP FORWARD.
WHER YOU STANDT
A LOT MORE WION THAT I THAT WE
SPEAKER PE IHAT WEFICANT
NT O ONEVE TO HELP SOLVE THE AT
THING,9 ICANT.
THAT I T'DE
AVPRE VERY MINOR
TO THE HF
AS A WHOLE. THE ENERGD CLIMAT
MODELERS SAID IT COU RGOAL -- ES
CAN YOU GIVE US A SE
CO F THECARBMITI
ELTRICITY.
OF EMISSNSONREDUCTION
SH ELECTRIC H EDED U
GINGETX
CREDITS FOR PURCLECTRI
VEHICLES, INCLUDING ED
TRIC
WEL E SPEE RET O
FACILITIESRN
D THEIR T
WIND
CIWE'LME
D MO BATTERY
THOSE ARE SOME O
SIGNIFICANT ITEMS.E ENVI ZED THE
E QUIRE THE VERNMENT TO AUCTION
OIL AND GAS LE ON FERA
O
DO WITH THOSCRITICISMS?
>> I DO.
AND THOSE ARE  IAID THERERT
LIKE.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE OVERALLOF
POLLN DUCTIONSWIOMHU RS
OVERWHELM THE  TE D.ARE IN A PR
COMPMIINTY SUPPORT.MPROMIAR TE A
OFHE ACHIEVEMENTS.
RSTAND SOM TSE
E COMPROMISED.
BUT THE REST OF THSO
HISTORIC, IT HAS TO BE PUT IN
PERSPECTE.
HIS IS GOING  UNLEASH SO MUCH MH
LEGISLATION.
>> AYOU LOOKUCKY AND MISSOURI, E
BEEN DEALINGNG WEEKS.
NTISTS HAVE BEEN
TELLINUSEST
CLIMATE CHANGE WILL MATHER
EVENTS LIKTHESE MORE
AND MORE PEOPLE?TSNGR MI
AND EVEN MANY OF THOSE W T COMF
OR ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
CARDS AND THEY'RE SEEINGRUIO
EVENING NEWSIKE A NATURE RIDE T
OF REVELATION SWE'VE HAD IFE
THOU-Y
WEEKS.
AT OARLD
% OF THE AMERICAN WESTS INE SCO
AT PEOPLE BY TEDION ANAST FEWEE.
AND IT'S L G
WORSE.
AND TH W
ON IN PREDICNG'V
H SHOULD BE GI
WERE RIGHT I WS OF WHAT WOULHAF
IT COMESO WHAT'S ND THE U.S. WHN
ERWORLD.HINKCRUCTHEY A GLOBA
WE ARE SECOND  THEM.
ANR TWO COUNTRIES IS
I'M HARDENED AT THE
NTIDPING ARE  MEEN.K ABOUT THFAT
EY HADD REACTION
BUT ITT END.D  SUSPENSKST
O
I HOPE THAT PREDICTION
T A LOT
THAT WIT TF TOO
MUCH MTIWE WILL SEE TH
A.
>>O BRWANT TK OUT JUSTHAEARNED .
EY OF
RESIDENCE WHIL.ENT M
A FORMER PRESIDENT WLD HAVE  DO
MANSIO NO, IT DOESN'T.
BUT I WANTHA T I
WHO KNOW.W THE
I KNOWD I
DON'T KNOW THAT OUR NATION HAS O
MM ACCORDING TE BOOKACCORDING T
OR THERDS CONFEN HIS PROEFTYD I
S HIS WORKED WITH
HIM S ME THETICE